On December 19th, 2018...
a revolution started to spread
throughout Sudan.
After decades of living under
President Omar Bashir’s
brutal military regime...
civilians pushed back.
They wanted a democracy
in their country.
A few months later,
this man and this man helped take down
Bashir in a coup...
and then promised protesters the future
they had demanded.
Four years later
the same two men are now
at war with each other...
tearing Sudan apart, killing
hundreds of civilians.
So how did Sudan go from this...
to this in such a short time?
And how did these
two powerful men...
go from partners to enemies?
[overlapping] -Clashes in Sudan.
-...a deadly coup...
... support forces...
Sudan has a long history of coups.
Leader after leader has been brought down
by military officers.
The country's official military
now known as the Sudanese
Armed Forces or SAF
has held tremendous power in the country
for nearly a century.
And they started using that power
soon after Sudan gained independence
from Anglo Egyptian rule.
“Sudanese flag now replacing
the flags of those two nations.”
The first successful military coup
happened in 1958.
Abdullah Kalil, a retired
military officer
and sitting prime minister...
overthrew his own civilian government
to put Sudan under military rule.
About a decade later, Colonel
Jaafar Nimeiry
carried out another successful coup...
bringing down a short lived democracy.
Then in 1985, Nimeiry was out.
This military officer took him down
and later installed a new
democratic government.
Four years later, Colonel
Omar Bashir took down
this government and appointed himself
as the new head of state.
But Bashir ended up being different
from those that came before him.
Given the pattern of military takeovers...
Bashir knew he may suffer
the same fate as previous leaders.
So he used a strategy called
coup proofing...
where he'd surround himself
with protectors
but would keep each one in check
so they couldn't overthrow him.
It started with the SAF.
Throughout his regime, Bashir
bolstered the army
and maintained a strong relationship with them.
He relied on them heavily
to crack down
on an ongoing civil war
in southern Sudan...
where SAF and allied militias
brutalized civilians on his command.
Then, with the army busy
in the south
another war started taking shape
in the West.
Darfur was in crisis.
People here were historically neglected.
Lack of medical supplies
and necessary goods
and little representation
in Sudan's government
left them feeling agitated for years.
So in 2003
while large portions of the army
were tied up in the South.
Rebel groups attacked troops
in this city in Darfur.
And Bashir in recognizing that
this rebellion was taking place
instead of relying on the Sudan Armed Forces
or SAF, the conventional military
he instead decided to
rely and arm
local Arab militias in the region
that were known as the Janjaweed.
This group was brutal
and focused on wiping out
Darfuri rebels and civilians
at Bashir’s direction.
Satellite imagery shows that the Janjaweed
is likely responsible
for destroying over 3000 villages.
SAF troops in Darfur were responsible
for destruction there as well.
Both groups are accused
of mass killing, rape
and the targeted displacement of civilians.
Together, they killed thousands
of Darfuris.
The events in Darfur showed
Bashir how to keep his power.
And he turned to the Janjaweed
in search of another protector.
Among the Janjaweed militias
there were a couple of men
Bashir trusted
and tried to bring into
the central government.
But there is one particular
Janjaweed leader
that Bashir trusted the most.
Mohamed Hamdan Dagalo  or Hemeti.
Bashir called him “my protection”.
A particular play on the Arabic word Hemmati
which is “my protection” versus Hemeti,
which is his nickname.
By 2011, the long and gruesome
civil war here ended
with South Sudan
gaining independence...
leaving Bashir in a weak position.
And soon after, Sudan's economy tanked.
Many of the oil resources
that sustain the country
were based in the South
which was no longer
under Bashir's control.
To strengthen his power
Bashir gave Hemeti and the
Janjaweed official status
as a paramilitary force called the
Rapid Support Forces, or RSF, in 2013.
At first, the group was placed under the NISS
Sudan's intelligence agency,
also one of Bashir's protectors.
Even though they were supporting the SAF
in the ongoing war in Darfur.
Then in 2017, he passed a law
placing Hemeti directly
under his command...
making it clear that the RSF’s main purpose
was to protect him.
To maintain the RSF’s loyalty
Bashir gave Hemeti financial autonomy
and allowed him
to take control of some of
Darfur's gold mines...
smuggle weapons and minerals
into places like Chad and Libya...
and send troops into war torn regions
in exchange for money.
At the same time, Bashir continued
to let the SAF have a hand
in major industries...
like weapon production and telecommunications.
While Bashir was busy making
these two forces richer
civilians continue to struggle.
Protests broke out in 2018
in the middle of a really bad
economic crisis.
That's when Bashir faced his biggest challenge...
putting his protection scheme to the test.
The ultimate trigger was
the government's budget...
which allocated about 60 to 70%
to the security sector...
which included Bashir's protectors.
While Sudanese people struggled
for basic needs.
This led to the biggest revolution
in Sudan's history.
Spontaneous protests broke
out in different parts of the country.
And then they shifted to Khartoum
in the capital city.
Bashir refused to leave office.
The RSF, SAF, and other security sectors
backed him...
and cracked down on the protesters
who ultimately wanted democracy.
But protesters didn't back down for months...
and it became clear to the RSF and SAF...
that Bashir's leadership wouldn't be
as useful to them anymore.
So on April 11th, 2019...
they made a move that surprised civilians
and Bashir.
SAF commanders colluded with
the RSF’s Hemeti
and removed Bashir from power.
Protesters celebrated Bashir's removal...
but they didn't trust the man
who made it happen.
A day after the coup, Abdel Fattah al-Burhan...
a formal regional commander in Darfur
took charge of the South.
Together, the two men gained control of Sudan.
People saw them as complicit
in the violence in Darfur
all those years ago, where they
worked together.
One as a member of the Sudan Armed Forces.
One as a militia leader on the same side...
against large proportions of the population of Darfur.
And soon, the two men turned on protesters.
When pro-democracy protests
kept intensifying in Khartoum...
Hemeti and his forces
started cracking down.
On June 3rd, 2019...
the RSF killed over 100 people
at a sit in protest.
And other massacres continued
throughout the country.
After this...
these countries were forced to step in
to help put Sudan on a democratic path.
The United States,
with its Arab allies
the United Kingdom, Ethiopia,
and the African Union...
pressured Sudan's military and protesters...
to accept a power sharing agreement.
In this new deal
representatives from both
the military and protesters...
would be part of a transitional council.
In this plan, the military would have control
for 21 months
and civilians for 18.
That meant the military would eventually
have to hand over power
to civilians who run the country.
The problem was, despite
warnings from protesters...
these two military men were put
in charge of the council
with Burhan as chair and
Hemeti as vice chair.
At first, the council acted in line
with the agreement...
and installed a new prime minister,
Abdallah Hamdok.
But after multiple military interventions
by these leaders...
like a staged coup in October 2021...
Hamdok resigned in January 2022.
That made Burhan, the de facto leader of Sudan...
and Hemeti as his number two again.
But Hemeti was never quite comfortable
with playing second fiddle.
Especially because he had
amassed this fortune
and had positioned himself
to play the role of statesman...
almost better than Burhan himself.
As Burhan developed personal alliances
with leaders
in the Middle East, Europe,
and Asia over the years.
Hemeti did the same using his riches
from the gold mines...
to build relationships with powerful individuals
in those countries as well.
After another year of protests...
the US, UAE, Saudi Arabia,
and the UK
pressured Burhan, Hemeti, and
protesters to sign another deal.
On December 5th, 2020
Burhan, Hemeti and political parties
signed it...
promising a new civilian-led
transitional government by April 2023.
But these two men disagreed
on a key part of the deal.
The RSF would need to become
part of Burhan’s army...
which would limit Hemeti’s power.
Burhan wanted that to happen
in two years.
But Hemeti proposed 10.
That disagreement caused a big rift
between Burhan and Hemeti...
which led to the current conflict between the two men.
They've placed hundreds of thousands
of armed men across the country.
Burhan and his army have an air force
that's responsible for many of the casualties.
And Hemeti’s finances allow him to arm
more and more men on the ground.
Hundreds of civilians have been killed already...
and thousands have fled Sudan.
Cease fires have routinely been broken.
And talks between the warring parties
have gone nowhere.
What was once a hopeful revolution
has been interrupted by these two men.
No matter who wins this war
protesters are left feeling betrayed...
by the country's de facto leaders
and also by the international community
that claimed to support their hopes
for democracy.